have some of these big bodies like this
in the right spots and rebounding as a
team just showing why this guy was the
best restricted area score last year in
the NBA no one scored more in the
restricted area last year than Yanis and
he's just shown why this guy was here
Katie
well coach bud got on them in that last
huddle defense Duffy started the game
really really sloppy the second three so
if he could defend he's a complete
player there's often going to be
traffic to forget about the ones you can
beat for the bucket bone toward the
final watch yeah let's watch this yeah
this just Oh coach is just he doesn't
even know oh my goodness
this just Oh coach is just he doesn't
even know pass ahead for Middleton yes
[Applause]
[Music]
is to doubt about a watch this this guy
I mean I I think cuz he looked at it but
I'll be honest didn't he have the right
to look at a guy when he done got him
like the old man won't there's bodies up
on Carol Anthony towns you cops it up to
Middleton slapping hands his right hand
his flexing his left as he comes up the
clerk he can't help each other yes
identical both